he says Satan is the invention of
Christianity
right yes the angel of the Lord is
called Satan
right yes how does that prove that there
isn't a figure called Satan just because
the word Satan can be used in a broader
sense for others for example didn't
Jesus call didn't Jesus call Judas a
devil in John 670 he did he did so does
that mean because the term devil can be
used in a generic sense to refer to
those who's in opposition to God that
doesn't mean it has a specific sense
referring to a specific Spirit
creature okay yes you did you understand
my point his logic is the same as since
the word devil can be used for humans
like Judas therefore there is no such
thing as the devil a spirit cre creature
in opposition to
God correct and that was uh when when I
saw this video I was just browsing
through the YouTube and that's when I
came across this video okay his logic is
listen to me Kenneth so we can help you
here his logic is this that because the
word Satan Satan the Hebrew word can be
used for other figures like the angel of
God or humans and that means the word
Satan cannot refer to a spirit creature
in opposition to God that's that's his
logic now that makes just as much sense
as you going to Matthew 16:23 read for
me go to Matthew
16:23 yes Matthew 16:23 yeah but he
turned and said unto
Peter get thee behind me Satan wait he
just called Peter
Satan yes okay so does that mean because
Peter's called Satan there isn't a
spirit creature called
Satan so was that Peter was that Peter
in the wilderness tempting Jesus or is
that the spirit creature called
Satan that Spirit Satan did you see how
the word Satan though used of humans and
others who oppose God doesn't mean it's
not used for a spirit creature who's in
opposition to God that's the logic this
Rabbi in his stupidity is using now go
to John 670 and try not to make too much
scratchy noise because it's blowing eard
drums Jesus answered them have I not
chosen you 12 and one of you is a devil
now 71 who is that devil verse 71 who's
that devil he spake of J Judas Iscariot
the son of Simon Okay stop right there
so Judas is called the devil Peter is
called Satan that means yes there is no
devil and Satan that's a spirit creature
because human beings are called devils
and satans you see how stupid that logic
is okay now let me show you from the Old
Testament there is a spirit creature
called Satan who opposes God and his
people go to job 1 verse6 there was a
day when the sons of God came to present
themselves before the Lord and Satan
came also among them wait this is in
heaven Angels sons of God sons of God
here means Spirit creatures they in
heaven who's this Satan in
heaven who's
who say it again Satan adversary devil
yes so who's this say in heaven what did
you say
earlier this is in heaven this is in
heaven the sons of God are approaching
God in heaven and Satan is right there
so who's the Satan that's in
heaven that's I I guess the real Satan
devil yeah how do we know it's the Satan
the scure because he goes and asks God
to allow him to T Jo
right that's in the context okay so this
is is a spirit creature who wants to
destroy the righteous on earth
right do you see that yes okay now go to
job 2 verse
one job 2 verse
one and there was a day when the sons of
God came to present themselves before
the Lord and Satan came also among them
to present them present himself before
the Lord now keep reading to
three and the Lord said unto Satan from
from whence comest thou and Satan
answered the Lord and said from going to
and fro in the earth and from walking up
and down in it and the Lord said unto
Satan hast thou considered my servant
job that there is none like him in the
earth a perfect and an upright
man one that fearth God and asth Evil
and still he holdeth fast his Integrity
although thou mest me against him to
destroy him without cause this is
clearly a spirit creature who was on
Earth looking for a victim now he's in
heaven to bring his case before God to
get permission to then punish this human
creature job and God gives him
permission
right yes okay so this is
not the angel of Jehovah being called
Satan because he opposes evildoers this
is not a human being called Satan it's a
spirit creature who's called Satan
because he oppos
oses the righteous Believers on earth
right yes now go to Zechariah Chapter 3
veres 1 and two and he showed me Joshua
the high priest standing before the
angel of the Lord and Satan standing at
the right hand at his right hand to
resist him and the Lord said unto Satan
the Lord rebuke thee Oh Satan even the
Lord that had chosen Jerusalem rebuke
thee is not this of brand plunked out of
fire okay so here is the Angel of the
Lord Joshua a righteous servant of God
has save from destruction and Satan to
accuse him this is a Heavenly scene this
is taking place in heaven where sat want
to accuse Joshua to get God to destroy
him but the angel of Jehovah who Jesus
defends Joshua and silences Satan it
says Lord rebuke you and shut your mouth
how dare you bring an accusation against
someone God has shown him favor does
that sound like Satan is a human
creature or a spirit creature who's in
heaven opposing and accusing the people
of
God Spirit creature okay so where did
this guy scac get that Satan is a
Christian invention now let me give you
one more are you
ready yes go to 1 Chronicles 21 verse1
1st Chronicles 21 verse1 and Satan stood
up against Israel and provoked David to
number Israel
okay Satan did what to David 1
Chronicles 21:1 he provoked David to
number Israel so does that sound like a
human creature or a spirit creature that
entices you to sin against God a spirit
creature okay so guys did you hear the
evidence Job chapter 1 verse6 Job
chapter 2 vers1 and read the entire
chapters right 1 Chronicles
21:1 and Zechariah 3: 1- 2 there you
have Satan referring to a spirit
creature H Satan a spirit creature who
opposes God's people to accuse them and
condemn them before God that sure sounds
like the Satan in the New Testament
right yes but I'm going to give you more
evidence now guys if you're not paying
attention you're you're not going to
learn how to refute this objection I'm
now going to give you more evidence from
the Bible that the Old Testament Saints
knew of Satan as a spirit creature who
opposes God and his people but under a
different name okay now I just gave you
the link to my article the name of the
article I'm going to give it to you too
brother just one second the name of my
article is called Satan in the Old
Testament part one I got to do a part
two folks Satan appears a lot more in
the Old Testament but under a different
name because people forget Satan has
many names Satan the devil B he's also
called B go to Mark 3 read
22 I want you to read
22 all to 27 Mark 322 to
27 okay for me and the scribes which
came down from Jerusalem said he ha B
Zeo and by the prince of devils casteth
Out cast out Devils did you catch it
brother before you go on another name
for Satan is what B see Belo the prince
of demons and we know the ruler of
demons is Satan right so notice how many
names Satan has Satan devil B right it
yes okay now let me show you another
name for a second go to 2 Corinthians
6:15 and what Concord hath Christ with b
b did you catch it or B or Bel but
that's the name of Satan okay now in
second Corinthians 6:15 here's another
name for Satan Bel or Bel belar it's the
same thing okay so notice Satan is
called the devil B Bel belar now where
do they get their word word Bel okay
guys this is only found in the King
James version I'm I going to start
reading verses where did they get the
word belile as a name of Satan now I'm
going to start reading it's in my
article save the article use the
references so now I'm going to read
brother now watch the name bile how many
times it appears in the Hebrew Bible but
your translation at times doesn't
translate the word but the King James
translates the word more regularly than
other translations Deuteronomy 13313
guys watch Deuteronomy 1313 and it all
refers to evil people evil women evil
men immoral idolatrous in opposition to
God what are they called certain men the
children of
Bel are G from among you and have
withdrawn the inhabitants of their City
saying let us go and serve other gods
which you have not known that's
Deuteronomy
13:13 judges 1920 22 judges 1922 it's
only in the King James guys why I don't
get rid of the King James contrary to
what monor Scholars will tell you now as
they were making their hearts merry
behold the men of the city certain sons
of B Judes 19:22 now as they were making
their hearts Mary behold the men of the
city certain sons of belile Sons of
belile there's that word again beset the
house about and beat at the door and
spake to the Master of the House the old
man saying bring forth the man that came
into the house that we may know him now
notice these sons of B wanted man that's
judges 1922 in Deuteronomy 13:13 the
children of B are those who entice
Israel to worship false gods notice
being a child of B is someone who's evil
Wicked immoral idolatrous judges
20:3 judges 20:3 judge
20:3 now Deliver Us the men the children
of B which are in giia so now the others
want to kill these children of B these
wicked men want the man and his
concubine that we may put them to death
and put away evil from Israel but the
but the children of Benjamin would not
hearken to the voice of their Brethren
the children of Israel now 1 Samuel
11:16 guys look how many references to
Bel 1st Samuel 11:16 could not thine
handmade
for a daughter of belile so a woman
who's a daughter B because she's wicked
and evil like her father bile because
bile is Satan a murderer and a liar for
out of the abundance of my complaint and
grief have I spoken hit her to 1st
Samuel 2:12 1 Samuel 21:12 now the sons
of Eli were sons of bile guys count how
many references to B and his children
bile and his children sons of the devil
the devil their father okay now the sons
of Eli were sons of B they knew not the
Lord that was 1 Samuel 2:12 1 Samuel
10:27 but the children of B said how
shall this man save us and they despised
him and brought him no presence but he
held his peace I'm going to skip 1
Samuel 251 17- 25 this is all in that
article 1st Samuel 25:1 17-25 it talks
about Nel the man of B he's a man of b 1
Samuel
30:22 1st Samuel 30:22 then answered all
the wicked men and Men of Bel of those
that went with David and said because
they went not with us we will not give
them a of the spoil that we have
recovered saved every man his wife and
his children that they may lead them
away and depart 2 Samuel
167 and thus said shemi when he cursed 2
Samuel 16:7 come out come out thou
bloody man and thou man of belile you
who belong to belile 2 Samuel 20 verse1
almost done Brother 2 Sam 20:1 and there
happened to be there a man of Bel whose
name was Sheba the son of a benjamite
and he blew a trumpet and said we have
no part in David neither have we
inheritance in the son of Jesse every
man to his tents of Israel First Kings
2110 and13 First Kings 21:10 and 13 and
S two men sons of bile and there came in
two men children of B and the men of B
witness against him finally
Chronicles
13:7 2 Chronicles 13:7 and there are
gathered unto him vain men the children
of belile and have strengthened
themselves against ROM the son of
Solomon when reom was young and
tenderhearted and could not withstand
them now this is just some of the many
references in the Bible in the Old
Testament to be and his children the men
of bile the sons of bile the daughter of
bile the children of Bel
that's why in Jewish tradition the de
Sea Scrolls and this is all in my
article brother you got to read it the
de Sea Scrolls produced by Jews before
the time of Christ and during the time
of Christ they have in one of their
Scrolls a war between mzc and belile in
this scroll belile is this the devil
Satan who's the king of evil and his
angels are evil and mzc and his angels
will destroy him so even the Jews before
and during the time of Christ knew that
belile is a name for Satan the king of
all evil spirits the King of Evil did
you get your
answer yes I did that's it